- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
La première question
va être posée
par monsieur Roger Vicot.
- Roger Vicot: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Dans quelques mois,
la France va accueillir
la plus importante compétition
sportive internationale
avec les Jeux Olympiques d'été.
Notre pays s'apprête
à cette occasion
à recevoir 16 millions
de touristes.
Lors des débats
sur la loi prévoyant
des mesures
de sécurité à mettre
en place pendant les JO,
notre groupe
a soutenu l'idée
que cette manifestation
exceptionnelle justifiait
des mesures exceptionnelles
tant que les libertés
fondamentales
étaient respectées.
Au fil des mois
et des semaines,
l'inquiétude grandit
sur cette question
de la sécurisation
des Jeux Olympiques.
Il y a quelques jours,
un touriste allemand
a été mortellement
touché en plein centre
de la capitale.
Vous avez mis en cause
le corps médical.
Je ne crois pas que le débat
soit là puisque,
quelles que soient
les responsabilités,
les faits sont là.
On sait par ailleurs
que des milliers
et des milliers d'agents
de sécurité doivent
être recrutés pour les JO.
Or, à huit mois
de la cérémonie d'ouverture
sur la Seine, pour laquelle
on attend plusieurs centaines
de milliers de personnes,
la machine semble considérablement
enrayée.
Les entreprises de sécurité
privées rechignent
à s'engager dans un nouveau
partenariat
avec l'Etat, n'ayant
toujours pas été payées
des prestations
de la Coupe du Monde
de rugby.
Pôle emploi fait de son mieux.
On cherche à recruter
coûte que coûte,
quel que soit le profil,
et surtout,
quels que soient
les risques
qui sont ainsi pris
en tentant de mettre
sur le terrain
des personnes
absolument pas formées
à des situations absolument
atypiques.
Quel est votre plan
de bataille
pour que la France
soit prête à temps?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
les mêmes critiques
et les mêmes
appréhensions ont eu lieu
pour la Coupe du Monde de rugby.
Cette Coupe du Monde,
grâce aux policiers,
aux gendarmes,
s'est déroulée
dans de parfaites
conditions de sécurité
et est saluée à travers le monde.
Pendant cette
Coupe du Monde,
qui est le quatrième événement
au monde organisé
par notre pays,
nous avons accueilli
le pape pendant deux jours
à Marseille
et en même temps le roi
et la reine d'Angleterre
à travers la France.
Pourtant, il y a eu les drames
qu'a connus Israël,
la montée du terrorisme
partout en Europe,
vous l'avez vu,
notamment à Bruxelles
et à Arras.
Des moyens
exceptionnels seront là
pour les Jeux Olympiques.
Le Parlement,
par deux fois, a voté
des textes qui nous ont aidés.
Je constate
que vous n'avez pas toujours
voté pour ces textes.
La présence systématique
de policiers
avec la création
de 11 escadrons
de gendarmes mobiles et de CRS.
Ce n'est pas
la peine
de crier avant d'avoir mal.
16.000 gendarmes
ont déjà été recrutés.
Tout le monde aura une carte
professionnelle.
C'est la loi
de sécurité globale,
que vous n'avez pas
non plus votée.
Cela permet à chaque agent
de sécurité privée
d'avoir une carte
professionnelle
et de ne pas connaître
une sous-traitance au-delà
d'un seul rang.
Ce n'était pas le cas
lorsque
vous étiez aux responsabilités.
La vérité,
c'est que vous êtes capable
dans la même
semaine de refuser
aux préfets
de police un QR code
pour accéder
à la cérémonie d'ouverture
et de nous demander
plus de fermeté.
Ce n'est pas très cohérent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Fanta Berete.
- Fanta Berete:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Des lieux symboliques
de ma circonscription
ont été frappés
par un homme
qui a fait couler le sang.
Toutes mes condoléances
à la famille
des victimes et des blessés.
Ces drames nous font
courir le risque
d'un basculement
de notre société,
si nous ne sommes pas
à la hauteur.
78% des Français
partagent ce propos.
L'idéologie des terroristes
s'engouffre
dans toutes les brèches.
Elle se sert
de nos failles et met
en place un piège
du face-à-face
dans lequel il ne faut pas tomber.
Nous opposer les uns
aux autres, voilà
ce qu'ils recherchent
et ce que nous propose
le RN.
Quand on nous dit
que la police
n'a pas fait son job,
je réponds mensonge.
A aucun moment
il n'y a eu de raté
des services français.
Le job a été fait
quand les agents
du 15e et du 16e
arrondissement
ont maîtrisé
l'assaillant rapidement
et sans armes à feu.
Je leur rends hommage.
Quand on dit que la justice
est laxiste,
je dis mensonge.
En prison et à sa sortie,
il a été placé
sous contrôle judiciaire.
Malgré le contexte
social qui met
de l'huile sur le feu,
malgré les récupérations
politiques et la volonté
de certains
de souffler sur les braises
pour diviser
et récolter les fruits
du chaos, soyons
à la hauteur
et ne livrons pas nos compatriotes
musulmans à la vindicte populaire.
Le tueur est né
à Neuilly de parents
qui ont fui
les mollahs
et qui ne lui ont pas donné
d'éducation religieuse.
La période que l'on traverse
est complexe.
Que répondez-vous
au président Bardella qui parle
de défaillance politique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la députée,
vous avez connu un drame,
un assassinat,
un acte terroriste
où un jeune homme allemand
est mort.
Je veux lui adresser,
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble
des victimes de cet
attentat, mes pensées
les plus fortes.
Quand il y a un attentat,
il y a toujours
à se poser des questions
pour savoir
si nous avons bien fait.
Aucune question
n'est taboue
pour la sécurité
de nos concitoyens.
Nous constatons
que la menace islamiste
touche le monde entier.
Ces attentats sont sur tous
les territoires européens,
occidentaux et internationaux.
La prégnance de cette menace
terroriste islamiste sera là
pendant longtemps.
Nous devons lutter
contre une idéologie radicale
qui veut en premier
lieu nous diviser
et toucher notre conception
de la liberté
et notre protection du monde.
Il y a, dans cet
attentat islamiste,
plusieurs questions qui se posent.
Avons-nous tous les moyens
de suivi judiciaire,
après la condamnation
en 2016
et une peine qui a été
intégralement effectuée
par cette personne?
Nous le pensons.
C'est pour ça
que nous avions fait
la loi de 2021
avec le garde des Sceaux.
Je regrette
que tout le monde ici
n'ait pas souhaité
voter ce texte
qui nous aurait
permis sans doute
pour les personnes
sorties de prison
après 2021 d'être dans le suivi
judiciaire.
Nous pouvons nous poser
des questions
sur l'injonction
et le suivi psychiatrique.
Nous connaissons le travail
des médecins psychiatres
et la difficulté
que nous avons désormais
de mettre des médecins
psychiatres partout.
Il ne faut pas trembler
pour lutter
contre la haine
dans les lieux de culte.
Quand je vois des gens
nous combattre
sur ce point
et ne pas voter la loi
de séparatisme,
je me dis que des gens cherchent
à nous diviser
et plutôt à gagner
les élections.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Alma Dufour.
- Alma Dufour:
Madame la Première ministre,
la trêve est finie.
Les bombardements
ont repris à Gaza.
L'enfer sur Terre
est revenu,
selon les mots
d'une responsable
de l'ONU.
1,9 million de Gazaouis
se sont déplacés
dans le sud à la demande d'Israël.
C'est désormais le sud
qui est bombardé.
16.000 personnes ont été
tuées, 6150 enfants.
Si les civils
ne meurent pas assassinés
par l'armée israélienne,
c'est la maladie
qui les tuera.
40.000 personnes souffrent
de dysenterie aiguë,
parce que l'eau
potable manque à Gaza.
La colonisation
a fait 243 morts
en Cisjordanie,
alors que le territoire
n'est pas contrôlé par le Hamas.
Les attaques au Liban
se multiplient
et des milices
pro-iraniennes s'en prennent
en retour à des bases
américaines
en Irak et en Syrie.
Combien de temps allez-vous
laisser Netanyahou mettre
en danger la sécurité
de la région?
Vivre dans une réalité sociale
et médiatique parallèle
vous permet sans doute
de vous regarder
dans une glace,
mais nous,
nous les voyons,
les vidéos
qu'on nous envoie
tous les jours,
de cadavres d'enfants,
avec leur nom écrit
sur le poignet
pour qu'on puisse
les identifier sous les décombres.
Des grands-pères
qui enterrent
leur petite-fille de 5 ans.
Des parents qui auraient
préféré mourir
avec leurs enfants.
Vous arrivez
à dormir la nuit,
mais les Français
n'y arrivent plus.
Emmanuel Macron a demandé
le cessez-le-feu,
mais quelques jours après,
Sébastien Lecornu
est allé rassurer
Israël du soutien
de la France.
Seuls les actes comptent.
Il faut prendre
des sanctions diplomatiques
et économiques
contre ce gouvernement assassin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Laurence Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Madame la députée,
je vous prie d'abord d'excuser
la ministre des Affaires
étrangères, Catherine Colonna,
qui est en Australie.
Vous déplorez
que la trêve
n'est pas tenue.
Je déplore que vous me posiez
une question
de politique politicienne.
Vous savez
que nous avons demandé
la trêve depuis plusieurs
semaines
et qu'elle a permis
de faire sortir
des otages du Hamas,
des femmes,
des enfants, des personnes âgées.
Cette trêve a permis
la libération
de quatre de nos otages,
quatre compatriotes.
Elle a permis de faire entrer
les humanitaires
en plus grand nombre,
de faire sortir
des blessés pris en charge
sur un bateau français.
La fin de l'accord
sur la libération d'otages,
c'est un drame
pour les otages
et leurs familles auxquels
je pense aujourd'hui.
Quatre Français sont toujours
portés disparus.
La fin de l'accord
signe aussi la fin
de la trêve et de nouvelles
souffrances
pour les Palestiniens
de Gaza qui subissent
une situation humanitaire
catastrophique.
La France a toujours
appelé au retour
de la trêve.
Elle poursuit
son action en faveur
des populations
civiles à Gaza
qui n'ont pas à payer
les crimes
du Hamas.
Catherine Colonna
va tenir demain
une conférence de suivi
de la situation humanitaire,
notamment en présence
des ONG actives
sur le terrain.
Ce sera l'occasion
de faire le point
sur les engagements
pris le 9 novembre
et d'avancer dans leur mise
en oeuvre concrète
au bénéfice des populations.
Au-delà de vos politiques
politiciennes, au-delà
de l'urgence,
la France, elle,
continue d'oeuvrer
avec le gouvernement
à un cessez-le-feu
nécessaire,
comme l'a rappelé
le président
de la République.
Peut-être
n'entendez-vous pas très bien.
D'ailleurs,
les consultations
se sont poursuivies au Qatar.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur le président
Olivier Marleix
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix:
Samedi dernier,
la France a été
encore une fois plongée
dans l'horreur
par un terroriste
se réclamant de l'Etat islamique.
Permettez-moi
d'avoir une pensée
pour la victime,
assassinée
alors qu'elle découvrait
Paris en amoureux
avec sa compagne.
Je veux rendre
hommage au sang-froid
des policiers
qui ont neutralisé
le tueur.
Applaudissements
L'auteur de cet attentat
était parfaitement connu
par les services de police.
En lien avec les assassins
de Samuel Paty,
il a passé
quatre ans en prison
pour avoir préparé un attentat.
Il était depuis suivi par la DGSI.
Il y a moins de deux mois,
sa mère s'est rendue
dans un commissariat
de police
pour demander
à ce qu'il soit surveillé
par la police.
Madame la Première
ministre,
vous êtes cheffe du gouvernement.
A ce titre, vous disposez
de l'administration.
Pouvez-vous nous dire
ce qui a été
fait depuis cette visite
au commissariat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président Marleix,
samedi dernier,
vous l'avez dit,
un homme a été tué
et deux autres personnes
ont été blessées,
victimes du terrorisme islamiste.
Je veux leur rendre hommage.
Je veux dire
ma solidarité
et celle
de mon gouvernement
à leur famille et à leurs proches.
Je veux saluer
à mon tour,
comme vous l'avez
fait, nos forces
de l'ordre et nos services
de secours.
Leur intervention rapide
a permis d'éviter
un bilan plus lourd encore.
Monsieur le président
Marleix,
comme vous,
je ne peux pas me satisfaire
que cette personne,
qui avait fait l'objet
d'un suivi judiciaire,
d'un suivi administratif,
qui était suivi
par nos services
de renseignement,
qui a fait l'objet
d'un suivi psychiatrique,
soit passé
à l'acte
et malheureusement ait tué
une personne samedi dernier.
Pour autant, je pense
que nous pouvons reconnaître
ensemble
que nous avons considérablement
renforcé notre arsenal
depuis 2017.
Je pense à la loi renforçant
la sécurité intérieure
et la lutte
contre le terrorisme,
qui a permis notamment
la surveillance
des individus
qui présentent une menace,
qui a permis
la fermeture des lieux
de culte où on fait
l'apologie du terrorisme,
qui permet la visite
des domiciles
des personnes suspectées
de représenter
une menace terroriste.
Je pense à la création du parquet
national antiterroriste
en 2019.
Je pense à la loi
de 2021 qui a permis
de créer une mesure
de prévention
de la récidive
terroriste en permettant
le suivi judiciaire
jusqu'à cinq ans
après la sortie de prison
des individus condamnés.
Je pense aussi à la loi
sur le séparatisme
qui permet de nous attaquer
aux racines
de la radicalisation.
Nous avons renforcé
le contrôle
des associations,
nous avons facilité
la fermeture
des lieux où on porte
la haine
de la République
et nous avons créé
un nouveau délit
de séparatisme.
Nous avons aussi
beaucoup renforcé
les moyens de la sécurité
intérieure
comme de nos services
de renseignement.
Cette détermination
porte ses fruits.
43 attentats ont pu
être déjoués
depuis 2017.
Je pense que ça mérite
d'être souligné.
Evidemment, suite
à ce drame, j'ai réuni
le ministre de l'Intérieur,
le ministre
de la Justice
et le ministre de la Santé
pour examiner
si des améliorations peuvent
encore être apportées
à notre dispositif.
La mère de ce terroriste
avait signalé
sa crainte sur l'évolution
de l'état psychiatrique
de son fils.
Nous lui avons conseillé
de demander
un placement d'office
de son fils,
ce qu'elle a refusé de faire.
Faut-il compléter
notre arsenal juridique?
Nous aurons à en débattre.
Nous sommes en train
de l'examiner.
Je peux vous assurer
que face au terrorisme,
nous devons évidemment,
à chaque fois, tirer
les leçons
de ce que nous avons pu
constater, et nous le ferons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le président?
- Olivier Marleix: Merci.
La réalité,
c'est que l'Etat ne parvient
plus à protéger les Français.
En 2023, le nombre
d'homicides
dans notre pays battra
tous les records
depuis 50 ans.
Voilà la vérité.
Les Français
attendent aujourd'hui
un changement radical.
Ce changement suppose
de ne pas détricoter
le texte du Sénat
de la loi immigration.
C'est ce que votre majorité
a fait
la semaine dernière.
Ce changement suppose
d'avoir le courage
de modifier notre code
de la nationalité.
Vous vous y refusez
systématiquement.
Ce changement
supposera enfin
et surtout de modifier
notre Constitution
pour reprendre en main
notre souveraineté
dans le domaine de l'immigration.
Vous vous y refusez encore.
Il ne sert à rien
d'avoir des ministres
qui courent
sur les plateaux télé
pour dire qu'ils n'ont
aucun tabou
pour protéger les Français
si vous refusez
une nouvelle
fois de modifier
notre Constitution.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Madame la Première ministre?
- Elisabeth Borne:
Je pense que ce débat
sur le texte immigration,
vous l'aurez
dans cet hémicycle,
mais en l'occurrence,
nous parlons
d'un terroriste
qui était français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
S'il vous plaît, un peu de calme.
S'il vous plaît...
S'il vous plaît,
on va passer la parole
à l'orateur suivant.
Monsieur Laurent
Esquenet-Goxes
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Laurent Esquenet-Goxes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à Prisca Thevenot.
Ce week-end, plus de 200.000
bénévoles, partout
sur le territoire,
vont lever des fonds
pour le Téléthon.
Partout,
ils vont se mobiliser
contre les maladies rares.
Cette collecte populaire,
la plus importante
au monde, est chaque année
un immense succès
grâce à eux.
En cette Journée
mondiale du bénévolat,
je leur exprime
ma profonde gratitude
et celle de l'ensemble
de la représentation nationale.
Plus globalement,
c'est le travail
de tous les bénévoles
qu'il faut saluer.
Moi-même, je sais la portée
d'un tel engagement.
Si 11 millions de Français
sont impliqués
dans une association,
ce chiffre
ne doit pas occulter
la crise du bénévolat.
Chez moi,
les associations rurales
sont particulièrement touchées.
Mardi dernier,
nous avons voté en commission
un texte destiné
à lutter
contre leurs difficultés
quotidiennes.
Ces associations
sont la cheville ouvrière
de la cohésion sociale.
Cette proposition
de loi simplifiera
la vie de ces structures
et va revaloriser l'engagement
bénévole.
Celle-ci a été
enrichie de mesures
que j'ai pu porter
en faveur de la formation
de bénévoles.
Concrètement, les nouveaux
retraités pourront mobiliser
leur CPF pour acquérir
les compétences indispensables
aux associations.
Certains
parmi les moins diplômés
n'osent pas franchir
le pas de l'engagement.
Ils ont peur de manquer
de qualification,
de faire par inadvertance
des erreurs.
Les compétences manquent,
alors agissons.
Quelles mesures
pourrions-nous prendre
dans pour favoriser
l'engagement
dans la vie associative?
Comment pouvons-nous
mieux accompagner
les bénévoles, notamment
dans la gestion financière,
humaine des associations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Permettez-moi,
en cette journée du 5 décembre,
de rendre hommage
à l'ensemble des 15 millions
de bénévoles qui oeuvrent
quotidiennement
pour notre pays
et dans nos territoires,
qui le font en dépit
des polémiques
qu'on pourrait
avoir sur leur prénom,
leur religion,
leur origine sociale
ou les territoires
où ils habitent.
Ils oeuvrent
pour défendre nos valeurs
de fraternité et de solidarité.
En ce sens,
vous avez raison,
nous devons continuer
à les valoriser,
à les accompagner et,
effectivement,
à simplifier leur vie
au quotidien, notamment
au travers
de la proposition de loi
qui a été portée
par l'ensemble
des groupes
de la majorité
et qui a été votée
à la quasi-unanimité
il y a quelques jours
en commission.
Cette loi porte
des enjeux concrets,
comme valoriser
le mécénat de compétences
pour les entreprises
de moins de 5000 salariés,
mais aussi faciliter le recours
au congé d'engagement citoyen,
mais également permettre
la valorisation
sur le compte
personnel de formation
des compétences
acquises dans le cadre
du bénévolat.
Si cette loi
nous a réunis, elle doit
nous obliger à aller plus loin.
C'est notamment
ce que nous avons fait
ce matin avec ma collègue
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
Nous avons ouvert
un site dédié
aux VAE de bénévolat
pour permettre
de valoriser
les compétences acquises
dans le cadre
du bénévolat au sein
des entreprises.
Continuons à avancer
et à valoriser.
Ne tombons pas dans les polémiques
vaines
quand il s'agit
de défendre l'honneur
de notre République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
la présidente
Marine Le Pen
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Marine Le Pen:
Madame la Première ministre,
une nouvelle attaque terroriste
islamiste assumée
et revendiquée
a provoqué la mort
d'un touriste
allemand et blessé
deux personnes.
Le bilan
n'est pas plus lourd
grâce au courage
de nos forces de l'ordre.
A chaque attaque,
les mêmes questions,
car à chaque attaque,
on découvre
un auteur connu,
repéré, surveillé,
et à chaque attaque,
les Français déplorent
que rien n'a été fait
pour le neutraliser.
A chaque attaque aussi,
nos compatriotes assistent
aux diversions médiatiques
et politiques.
Non, la question
n'est pas le suivi psychiatrique,
mais la neutralisation
de quelqu'un
dont les prédispositions
idéologiques,
le parcours criminel
et les revendications
sont parfaitement cohérents.
L'islamisme
n'est pas regardé en face
mais minoré, pas analysé
mais invisibilisé,
pas affronté mais contourné.
Vous venez d'ignorer
qu'une bonne partie
des terroristes est issue
de l'immigration,
car cela mettrait en cause
les responsabilités passées
et présentes
dans la submersion migratoire
que nous subissons.
Je vous le dis
avec gravité et regret,
cette dérobade
n'est pas responsable.
En ce qui nous concerne,
nous ne nous déroberons pas.
Pour combattre
l'islamisme,
je vous renvoie
à ma proposition
de loi visant à combattre
les idéologies islamistes déposée
en février 2021.
Pour combattre
les islamistes,
nous avons aussi
des mesures: expulser
les personnes qui présentent
des menaces, déchoir
de leur nationalité
les binationaux,
comme c'est le cas
du terroriste
du pont de Bir Hakeim.
Les solutions efficaces
et dissuasives existent.
Etes-vous prête
à prendre ces mesures
et à les mettre en oeuvre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Madame la présidente
Le Pen,
quand la France
est touchée,
il y a ceux qui agissent
en responsabilité,
et il y a vous et votre parti
qui,
une nouvelle fois,
vous précipitez
dans le seul but
d'alimenter les polémiques.
Vous qui ne respectez
jamais le travail
des enquêteurs et de la justice
et tirez toujours
des conclusions
sans même connaître
les faits.
Vous qui remettez
en cause le travail
de nos services
de renseignement
et de nos forces de l'ordre.
Depuis 2017, malgré une menace
qui ne cesse
de se renouveler
et de s'adapter,
43 attentats ont été déjoués,
1500 personnes
ont été interpellées
devant la justice.
Pendant ce temps, où étiez-vous?
Où étiez-vous en 2017
avec vos députés
lors du vote
de la loi renforçant
la sécurité intérieure
et la lutte
contre le terrorisme,
une loi qui permet
de fermer les lieux
de culte où on propage
la haine et qui facilite
les mesures
de surveillance individuelle?
Vous ne l'avez pas votée.
Où étiez-vous en 2019,
à la création
du parquet national
antiterroriste?
Vous avez voté contre.
Où étiez-vous en 2021,
lors de la création
du délit de séparatisme?
Vous ne l'avez pas voté.
Où étiez-vous
quand nous avons donné
des moyens inédits
à nos services
de renseignement?
Vous vous y êtes opposée.
Madame Marine Le Pen,
les faits
sont simples.
Le Rassemblement National s'est
systématiquement opposé
aux mesures pour la protection
des Français.
Nous agissons, vous polémiquez.
Nous prenons
des mesures,
vous êtes dans la posture.
Vos votes parlent d'eux-mêmes.
Nous sommes du côté des actes.
Nous prenons
nos responsabilités
pour protéger les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Frédéric Maillot.
- Frédéric Maillot:
Mes chers collègues,
nous sommes le 5 décembre 2023.
Il y a 10 ans,
un grand homme d'Etat
nous quittait.
Il était connu sous le nom
de Madiba, c'était Nelson Mandela.
C'était un homme de paix
qui a combattu l'apartheid,
la discrimination
et l'oppression
de son peuple.
Cet homme que l'Occident
aimait décrire
comme terroriste
et qui a finalement
vu l'histoire lui donner raison,
jusqu'à devenir prix Nobel
de la paix en 93.
Il a fait de sa vie
un combat
pour la paix, adepte
de la non-violence.
La non-violence,
c'est le but auquel
je souscris.
Il nous faut avancer vers la paix.
Est-ce un hasard
du calendrier
si le conflit
israélo-palestinien hante
nos débats depuis deux mois
et que ces images hantent
nos esprits et nos consciences?
Face à l'horreur,
ne faisons pas partie
de ceux qui se contentent de peu.
Nous ne voulons pas voir
couler le sang
et les larmes.
Nous voulons la paix.
Nous ne voulons pas
que les enfants grandissent
sous le bruit des bombes,
nous voulons
la paix.
Madame la Première
ministre,
quelles solutions
la France a-t-elle prévu
de mettre en oeuvre
pour faire avancer
la paix?
Quand est-ce que la France
prendra
sa part pour l'arrêt
des massacres inhumains
qui touchent des vies innocentes?
Nous savons très bien
que notre liberté
est incomplète sans la liberté
des Palestiniens.
Là où il n'y
a pas de justice,
il n'y a pas de paix.
Battons-nous
pour qu'advienne la paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Laurence Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Je l'ai dit
précédemment,
nous avons demandé la trêve.
Nous continuons
de demander la trêve
et de parler de paix.
C'est d'abord un drame
pour les familles
des otages, pour les familles
des portés disparus.
Je voudrais
que nous ayons une pensée
pour nos quatre compatriotes
portés disparus.
Leur libération,
et nous le demandons,
doit intervenir immédiatement.
La prise d'otages
est un crime abject,
contraire
à toutes les normes
de la morale.
La position de la France
a toujours été
très claire.
Elle repose sur trois piliers:
sécuritaire, humanitaire
et politique.
Sécuritaire,
nous l'avons dit,
c'est le droit d'Israël
de se défendre
dans le respect
du droit international.
Humanitaire,
je le répète,
c'est la protection
des civils à Gaza,
c'est la trêve
que nous avons demandée
encore et toujours.
Politique, car il n'y
aura pas de paix
sans solution politique.
Il faut une solution
politique
à deux Etats.
La France a toujours
été très claire
et a oeuvré sur ce sujet.
Je vous remercie
de m'avoir écoutée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Deux secondes.
Non, vous aviez écoulé
votre temps, désolée.
Vous aviez même eu du rab!
La parole est à Stéphane Vojetta.
- Stéphane Vojetta: Merci.
Cette question s'adresse
à Gérald Darmanin.
Ce dimanche,
Ruth Elkrief faisait
son travail,
en posant des questions
à Manuel Bompard.
Il y a eu des réactions
sur X, en taxant
la journaliste
de "manipulatrice
qui méprise les musulmans".
Lundi dernier, c'était
le journaliste Patrick Cohen
qui évoquait le drame de Crépol.
Une députée du RN
a ensuite saisi l'Arcom.
Samedi, il a fait
l'objet de menaces
dans plusieurs manifestations
d'extrême droite.
Il est choquant de voir
des responsables politiques
proférer des appels
à peine voilés
à la haine des journalistes,
particulièrement
dans le climat actuel.
Certes, les méthodes évoluent.
Fini les lettres
de dénonciation anonymes.
C'est désormais Twitter
que nous utilisons
pour coller une cible
dans le dos
de ceux qui nous déplaisent.
Selon l'Unesco,
86 journalistes
ont été assassinés
dans le monde
en 2022,
dont la moitié en dehors
de l'exercice de leurs fonctions.
Avons-nous déjà
oublié Charlie Hebdo?
Ne nous y trompons pas.
L'incitation à la haine
et à la violence n'a rien
à voir avec la liberté
d'expression.
Il s'agit d'une
infraction punie
par la loi et qui constitue
un délit soumis
à des peines
d'emprisonnement
si cela est public.
Comment pouvons-nous
collectivement défendre
la liberté de la presse
et que peut faire
le gouvernement
pour protéger tous
ceux qui l'incarnent?
A défaut de poursuites
judiciaires, faudrait-il
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et les responsables politiques
qui incitent à la violence
soient fichés S?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député Vojetta,
les policiers
et gendarmes du service
de la protection
des personnalités
n'agissent pas
parce qu'ils soutiennent tel
ou tel courant de pensée
ou de religion.
Ils sont là
pour protéger
ceux qui sont menacés.
C'est le cas des responsables
religieux, juifs
ou musulmans.
C'est le cas
de responsables politiques
qui trouvent refuge dans le pays.
C'est le cas de magistrats
antiterroristes
comme de journalistes.
Louis Boyard a pu
être protégé
par la police.
C'est l'honneur
de la police
que de le protéger.
Monsieur Bardella
a pu être protégé
par la police.
Monsieur Zemmour
est actuellement protégé
par la police.
C'est normal
que les gens menacés
parce qu'ils ont
des opinions,
parce que d'autres
leur mettent
des cibles dans le dos,
soient protégés
par des policiers
qui risquent
leur vie,
comme ce policier
qui est mort à Charlie Hebdo
pour protéger
des journalistes dans leur action.
Madame Elkrief a déjà été
sous protection.
Elle a été déjà menacée
très sérieusement.
Elle a eu
de très nombreuses menaces
de mort.
Pendant des jours
et des nuits,
elle comme sa famille
ont pu être protégées.
Ces menaces
se sont amoindries
avec le temps
et sa protection a été levée.
Il est certain
que d'après les analyses
du ministère
de l'Intérieur,
les propos
de monsieur Mélenchon
qui lui ont mis une cible
dans le dos méritent
une protection.
J'invite chacun à mesurer
les propos publics
que nous pouvons tenir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Paul-André Colombani.
- Paul-André Colombani: Merci.
Une étude
surprenante affirme
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
de rehausser
les coefficients
géographiques en Corse
ou en Guadeloupe.
Nos hôpitaux en outre-mer
sont dégradés.
La méthode de calcul
de ce coefficient doit
être cohérente.
C'est un biais
statistique majeur
que de penser
que le surcoût peut
se limiter au prix.
C'est ignorer que l'essentiel
des activités
et des charges
attenantes exigent
une prise en compte
des volumes réalisés.
A ce titre, l'analyse des 40
premiers groupes
est édifiant.
12.341 patients en moyenne
sur le continent.
Les surcoûts sont principalement
constitués d'une moindre
utilisation des plateaux
techniques.
Je peux prendre
un exemple très parlant.
En Corse, nous faisons
27 prothèses
de hanche par établissement
contre 131
sur l'Hexagone.
Dès lors, il me semble
urgent d'associer
la Corse à la mission
flash relative
à la réévaluation.
Il faut
que tout cela soit en adéquation
avec nos besoins.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
vous évoquez
la situation du coefficient
géographique.
Permettez-moi d'abord
d'avoir une pensée
pour tous les personnels
de l'hôpital d'Ajaccio
qui ont fait face cette nuit
à une grosse inondation,
avec une coupure d'électricité.
Ils ont tout fait
pour évacuer les patients
sans risques.
Ils sont encore
aujourd'hui
en train de réparer les avaries.
Vous avez évoqué
une étude qui a conclu
que sur la Corse et d'autres
départements ultramarins,
il n'était pas nécessaire
de rehausser
le coefficient géographique.
Cependant, il est nécessaire
de le rehausser ailleurs.
C'est après nos premiers
échanges
que j'ai demandé
à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de gros écarts
ou de gros problèmes
de comptabilisation.
C'est un premier regard
qui a été fourni
lors de cette étude.
Je suis évidemment
prêt
à ce que cette étude
vous soit fournie,
parce qu'il n'y
a pas de confiance s'il n'y
a pas de la transparence.
Vous y serez évidemment associé.
Deuxièmement,
je suis aussi prêt
à ce que cette étude,
qui a été faite
par les services
du ministère à ma demande,
soit challengée,
pour parler en bon français,
et notamment
des particularités
que connaît la Corse.
Enfin, il y a eu
une mission flash
et mes équipes et moi
recevrons bientôt
vos collègues ultramarins,
et je pense
que le coefficient
géographique
est spécifique à la Corse.
En conclusion, il n'y
a pas que le coefficient
géographique
pour prendre en compte
les spécificités insulaires.
L'hôpital d'Ajaccio a fait l'objet
d'investissements publics.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Jean-Claude Raux.
- Jean-Claude Raux:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
"Madame la mairesse,
c'est une bouffonne.
Dès que je sors,
je vais la buter."
Ce sont les mots
adressés hier
à une maire de ma commune.
C'est une nouvelle
menace on ne peut
plus explicite.
Elle provient
d'un jeune homme
sous curatelle nécessitant
des soins psychiatriques
et livré à lui-même
depuis deux ans.
Récemment, il y a eu
des passages
à l'acte
comme de la torture
sur des animaux, entre autres.
Laisser périr
la psychiatrie,
c'est accroître
la violence
dans notre société.
C'est accepter
que les élus soient
en première ligne.
C'est accepter le suicide
d'une jeune fille
dans mon département
après qu'elle a été violée
dans une unité pour adultes.
C'est accepter l'emprise
des groupes terroristes
sur les mineurs.
Ici, nous nous contentons
de réprimer
et de réagir.
Une politique
de santé publique
de la psychiatrie
contribue à l'apaisement
de la société
et à la prévention
des violences.
Votre action à l'égard
de la santé mentale
a des répercussions
sur la fermeture
des lits.
La liste est très longue.
Notre contexte,
c'est celui du manque
de soignants qui s'aggrave.
En Loire-Atlantique,
la pénurie médicale
dans les services médicaux
atteint maintenant 50%
à certains endroits.
Au CHU de Nantes,
54 postes infirmiers manquent
en psychiatrie.
Nous alertons sans cesse
sur les situations
en Pays-de-la-Loire.
La crise est nationale,
mais les implications
sont locales.
Faudra-t-il attaquer l'Etat
pour non-assistance
à personnes en danger
pour enfin remettre
du soin à la place de la violence?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
mesdames et messieurs,
votre raccourci
entre les actes
est insoutenable.
Vous sous-entendez
que le gouvernement laisse dépérir
la psychiatrie.
C'est honteux.
Vous avez évoqué
toute une série
de choses.
Le gouvernement,
depuis trois ans
est dans l'action
et notre objectif
a augmenté de 33%.
Vous avez raison,
c'est une spécialité médicale
qui est choisie en dernier
par les internes.
Nous ne pouvons pas
les forcer,
mais nous avons aujourd'hui
baissé
de 16% à 5%
le nombre de postes
qui n'était pas choisis
en internat.
Tout ce que décrivent
les élus locaux,
ce n'est pas qu'une
question psychiatrique.
Il est pour moi
trop facile de considérer
que c'est une question
psychiatrique.
C'est précisément
parce que l'on a laissé
tout à la psychiatrie
que l'on s'est trompés.
C'est un sujet
global
que nous nous prenons
en pleine figure.
Nous devons aborder
l'aggravation
de la prise en charge,
le bon soin
avec les bons soignants
au bon moment.
Aujourd'hui, l'engagement
du gouvernement
est total.
Je l'ai indiqué
lors de la discussion générale
du PLFSS.
L'engagement
du gouvernement est total
pour que le prochain
PLFSS supporte
encore plus les enjeux
de santé mentale.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes
en train de reconstituer
par les infirmiers
en pratiques avancées
en santé mentale,
par les psychiatres
que nous recrutons,
par les secouristes
en santé mentale,
toute une série
de réponses qui n'existaient pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Roger Chudeau
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Roger Chudeau: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
les résultats
pour 2023 viennent
de tomber.
Nous pouvons baptiser ce nouveau
désastre éducatif "génération
Hollande".
Encore bravo
aux socialistes
et aux macronistes!
Pendant six ans,
vous n'avez rien
fait de sérieux.
Le dédoublement
en REP a provoqué
un simple frémissement.
Vous tentez une politique
de diversion.
Regardons les mesures
que vous avancez:
au primaire, allongement
des programmes.
Allonger
les programmes lorsque
nos enfants savent déjà
si peu de choses
qu'il faut supprimer
les pseudo-enseignements
dont vous êtes si friands:
éducation sexuelle,
pseudo-développement durable...
Au collège,
vous rétablissez enfin
les groupes de niveau
dans les matières,
et il faut
transformer le brevet
en examen de passage en seconde.
Je vois que vous connaissez
le fonctionnement
du photocopieur.
Ce sont les mesures exactes
du programme éducatif
de Marine Le Pen!
Vous avez de bonnes
compétences en lecture.
Vous décidez
que l'enseignement
des mathématiques
doit être ignoré?
Mais que faites-vous du français?
Avez-vous parlé du désastre
de l'orthographe?
Ou de l'histoire de France?
Comment rénover
l'enseignement
sans repenser
la formation initiale
des professeurs?
Enfin,
il ne vous aura pas échappé
que les auteurs
des attentats, des émeutes
et des attaques
de ces dernières années,
sont tous passés par l'école.
Vous ne dites pas un mot
de l'enseignement dispensé
en REP.
Pas un mot sur l'échec
de l'assimilation
par l'école.
Ces quartiers sont des véritables
cocottes-minute sociales.
Au total, votre opération
de communication ignore beaucoup
trop de sujets.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal, ministre
de l'Education nationale.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député Chudeau,
les résultats Pisa
de nos tests sont tombés
aujourd'hui.
Ils confirment les résultats
de l'évaluation
que j'avais
commandée
il y a quelques semaines.
Les élèves
qui ont passé ces tests
de l'année dernière
étaient en sixième
en 2017,
quand nous avons réinvesti
massivement sur l'école primaire.
Nous voyons
que le réinvestissement massif
sur l'école primaire
de la majorité commence
à porter ses fruits.
Vous avez parlé
de frémissement,
mais c'est assez négatif
pour les enseignants eux-mêmes
qui permettent
au niveau de commencer
à s'élever.
Il faut aller plus loin
sur le primaire,
transformer
notre organisation au collège
et au lycée.
C'est ce que j'ai présenté
ce matin
aux enseignants.
Enfant,
il y a une philosophie
qui est importante,
c'est celle d'une école
de la sincérité de la vérité.
La sincérité,
c'est la première marque
de respect et de l'élévation
de niveau.
Quand on dit
à un élève
qui ne sait pas lire
à la fin
de son CP qu'il peut
passer en CE1,
on lui envoie
message
qu'on ne croit pas en lui.
Quand on dit
aux familles
que ce sont elles qui
ont le dernier mot
sur le redoublement,
on envoie le message
qu'on ne croit pas
aux enseignants.
Quand on dit
que les épreuves du brevet
et du baccalauréat peuvent
être artificiellement modifiées
pour atteindre un taux
de réussite souhaité,
quel message envoie-t-on
à la jeunesse
et à la société?
On ne croit pas à la valeur
du travail
et du diplôme.
Ce sont tous ces tabous
que je souhaite briser
avec des mesures
concrètes sur lesquels
nous reviendrons.
L'objectif est unique:
permettre
à tous nos élèves de réussir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Isabelle Rauch
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Isabelle Rauch: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Les livraisons de cette étude
sont rarement agréables
à la France
et ce millésime 2023
ne déroge pas à ce constat.
Il y a une baisse de 15 points
en mathématiques
et en compréhension de l'écrit.
La proportion des élèves
performants progresse peu.
Cette question
inquiète les Français
et elle participe
à cette impression
de déclassement.
Notre groupe se félicite
des annonces
que vous venez de faire
pour rétablir l'autorité
des professeurs,
offrir de meilleures conditions
d'apprentissage,
se concentrer
sur les savoirs fondamentaux...
Ces annonces
complètent
celles qui ont été faites
sur le harcèlement scolaire
et les carrières des enseignants.
Avec lucidité,
nous avons des obstacles
à franchir.
Certains de ces obstacles
sont nombreux dans la société:
la place des écrans,
la confiance
dans l'avenir,
la transmission parentale.
D'autres sont organisationnels:
un professeur face
à chaque enfant
avec des bons manuels.
Ensuite, il y a des principes:
le respect
du professeur,
la valeur des diplômes...
Sommes-nous
condamnés à observer
cette longue chute face
à chaque évaluation?
Comment pouvons-nous
inverser la donne?
Comment assurer
aux Français
que nous serons
désormais en mesure
de regagner notre rang?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Parmi tous
les points
que vous avez évoqués,
je vais m'arrêter
sur la question des mathématiques.
Une grande nation,
c'est une nation mathématique.
On ne peut pas se satisfaire
de la chute massive
du niveau en mathématiques,
encore constatée
à l'occasion
des résultats de Pisa.
J'ai annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures
pour relever le niveau
des élèves français
en mathématiques.
Ca commence
à l'école primaire
avec des manuels
en mathématiques labellisés
avec les enseignements
de la science
et de la pratique
et dont toutes les écoles
primaires seront dotés.
Les groupes de niveau au collège
seront instaurés
pour faire progresser
tous les élèves,
alors que la trop grande
homogénéité pousse certains
à stagner.
Au lycée, nous allons renforcer
le volume horaire
en terminale professionnelle
des mathématiques,
dispenser des enseignements
des mathématiques
en petits groupes.
J'assume le souhait que la France
adopte désormais
la méthode de Singapour
pour l'enseignement
des mathématiques,
qui a fait ses preuves
dans 70 pays,
qui a été construite
avec des racines françaises.
Ferdinand Buisson expliquait
qu'il fallait commencer
par le concret avant l'imagé.
Nous allons créer
une nouvelle épreuve
de mathématiques
anticipée
pour tous les élèves
en fin de primaire.
Nous considérons
que la maîtrise
des mathématiques
est fondamentale
dans le socle de tous les élèves.
Notre culture est aussi
scientifique.
Désormais,
l'ensemble des élèves
en fin de première auront
une épreuve anticipée
de mathématiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la présidente?
- Isabelle Rauch:
Merci pour ces annonces
et pour ce programme ambitieux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Ugo Bernalicis.
- Ugo Bernalicis:
Madame la présidente,
la cour
de justice
de la République a prononcé
la relaxe d'Eric Dupond-Moretti,
le garde des Sceaux.
Nous voilà face à une décision
abracadabrantesque!
Et prise face à des collègues
qui constatent
"que l'élément de prise
illégale d'intérêts
est établi".
Mais apparemment,
il n'y
aurait pas "d'éléments
intentionnels".
Le ministre
n'aurait pas "la conscience
nécessaire" pour effectuer cela.
Le voici malgré lui condamné
à l'innocence!
Un véritable bras
d'honneur à la justice
et à l'application du droit.
Le pourvoi en cassation
semblait évident.
Ce lundi, par la voix
du procureur général,
vous avez proposé
de tourner la page
et de regarder vers l'avenir.
S'il y a une page
à tourner,
c'est celle de la CJR,
qui a fait
la démonstration de son échec.
Les macronistes
proposaient déjà
de la supprimer en 2018.
Il est nécessaire de maintenir
une certaine spécificité afin
de renforcer la légitimité
démocratique
et de garantir l'impartialité
et l'indépendance
de la justice.
Allez-vous proposer un projet
constitutionnel supprimant
la Cour
de justice
de la République
et incluant l'information
de jugement par un jury populaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Franck Riester.
- Franck Riester:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur Bernalicis,
vous n'êtes ni procureur ni juge.
Avec votre question,
vous piétinez l'autorité
de la chose jugée.
Comme vous avez piétiné
pendant des mois
la présomption d'innocence.
Comme vous le savez,
la Cour de justice
de la République
est une juridiction composée
de magistrats professionnels
et de parlementaires
de tous les groupes,
y compris le vote.
Madame Obono
était l'une des juges!
Après une enquête
et une audience,
avec l'audition
de nombreux témoins,
elle a délibéré
et elle a décidé
la relaxe du garde des Sceaux.
Le procureur général
de la Cour de cassation
a annoncé
qu'il ne formulerait pas
de pourvoi contre cette décision.
Elle est donc définitive.
Nous devons respecter
nos procédures,
monsieur
le député,
ainsi que notre droit
et notre Constitution.
Nous n'avons pas à commenter
des décisions
de justice.
Nous devons
respecter l'autorité
de la chose jugée.
Le ministre de la Justice
est à la tâche,
comme depuis le premier
jour,
dans le cadre
de la feuille de route
qui lui a été fixée
par le président
de la République
et par la Première ministre.
Monsieur le député,
vous me demandez
si la Cour
de justice
de la République
doit être supprimée.
C'est un débat
constitutionnel
qui a déjà été posé.
Des réflexions ont eu
lieu dans le cadre
des Etats généraux de la justice.
Il s'agirait d'une réforme
constitutionnelle majeure
qui toucherait
au principe cardinal
de la séparation des pouvoirs.
Elle nécessite une forme
de consensus politique.
La justice a tranché,
respectez-la!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député?
- Ugo Bernalicis:
Moi aussi, je vais
vous répondre:
je pense qu'il faut supprimer
la Cour de justice
de la République.
Vous devrez en répondre
devant le peuple,
comme vous le proposiez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Fabienne Colboc
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Fabienne Colboc: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre Prisca Thevenot.
En ce jour
de la Journée mondiale
du bénévolat
et du volontariat,
je voudrais exprimer
toute notre reconnaissance
et notre soutien
aux 15 millions
de bénévoles.
Ils sont des maillons
essentiels
de notre société.
Ils sont ceux qui font
la différence,
qui créent des liens
et qui transforment
des vies.
Mesdames et messieurs
les engagés,
que vous soyez
bénévoles au sein
de petites ou grandes
associations,
votre engagement est immense.
Nous l'avons vu
encore ce matin
sur l'île Saint-Denis.
Nous devons cependant
reconnaître
que l'engagement bénévole
est parfois découragé
par des obstacles
administratifs,
financiers ou humains.
Dès 2017, nous avons agi
pour accompagner
et soutenir nos associations.
Je pense notamment au fonds
de développement
de la vie associative,
qui est abondé
dans le cadre du PLF 2024 de 20
millions d'euros supplémentaires.
Avec la proposition de loi
de mon collègue,
nous portons des mesures
concrètes visant
à valoriser et simplifier
la vie associative.
Par ces mesures
adoptées en commission,
je retiens l'assouplissement
des conditions
pour accéder à des droits,
l'ouverture
du mécénat de compétence
aux entreprises
de moins de 5000 salariés...
Je tiens
à vous remercier
pour votre infatigable
engagement
au sein de la vie
associative
et pour les bénévoles.
J'aimerais vous interroger
sur l'engagement
des jeunes.
On entend
qu'ils ne s'engagent plus.
J'ai monté un conseil
sur l'engagement
des jeunes,
et je peux vous dire
leur détermination à vouloir
se rendre utiles.
Quel retour
avez-vous des jeunes
au regard de vos nombreux
déplacements?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Effectivement, aujourd'hui,
c'est occasion
de saluer l'engagement
de nos bénévoles.
Si nous devons
saluer le fait
que nous sommes une nation engagée
fondamentalement,
nous ne devons pas oublier
que nombre
de nos bénévoles
sont des jeunes,
voire des très jeunes.
Nous avons pu le voir ce matin
sur l'île Saint-Denis.
J'ai pu le voir
dans toutes les villes
de France, nos jeunes
s'engagent à travers
le tissu associatif
et à travers
le service civique et le service
national universel.
J'aime à le rappeler,
ce n'est pas simplement l'alpha
et l'oméga
de l'engagement,
mais bien le pied d'entrée
dans un engagement
par l'action.
C'est dans une démarche
de résilience
et d'ambition que nous devons
porter collectivement.
Récemment, notre pays
a été frappé
par des intempéries,
et à ce titre,
de nombreux jeunes et de nombreux
députés m'ont sollicitée
pour savoir comment
nous pouvions mobiliser
ces jeunes dans le cadre
du SNU en dehors
du standard habituel.
J'ai décidé de créer
des brigades citoyennes SNU
qui permettent à nos jeunes...
Je suis heureuse
que la gauche salue
ces brigades!
Dans le cadre
de ces brigades,
nos jeunes peuvent
venir en renfort
des maires et des élus
locaux, une fois
les lieux sécurisés
pour aller recréer
du lien, là
où nos concitoyens
étaient apeurés et éloignés.
Nous ne devons pas crier
sur notre jeunesse,
mais en être fiers,
la mettre
au devant de la scène.
Notre jeunesse
est libre et engagée,
et nous devons pouvoir l'honorer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Frank Giletti.
- Frank Giletti: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Lundi prochain,
nous débuterons
dans cet hémicycle
l'examen d'un projet
de loi ayant pour vocation
de contrôler
plus sérieusement l'immigration.
En revanche,
cela épargne un pays
en particulier: l'Algérie.
Les Algériens forment
la première communauté
en France,
mais l'immigration algérienne
se voit facilitée
et encouragée
par l'existence d'un traité
franco-algérien datant
de 1968.
Votre gouvernement
ne l'a toujours
pas remis en cause.
Le gouvernement d'Alger
avait pourtant refusé
de délivrer
des laissez-passer
il y a quelques mois.
En termes de liberté
d'établissement,
ces derniers
sont les seuls dispensés
de prouver la viabilité
de leur projet.
L'immigré algérien
qui voudrait obtenir
un certificat
de résidence
avec son conjoint
n'est pas tenu d'apporter
la preuve d'un minimum
de six mois
de vie commune.
Nous savons qu'en
général, la volonté
du ministère de l'Intérieur
se heurte vite
aux impératifs du Quai d'Orsay.
Mais si l'on en croit
son action
au Proche-Orient,
ce dernier détient-il
encore une voix sur la scène
internationale?
Vous êtes le premier à savoir
qu'en ignorant l'obstacle posé
par cet accord bilatéral,
votre projet
de loi est non
seulement insuffisant,
mais en plus incomplet.
Pour paraphraser
votre collègue Manuel Valls,
"il est urgent de changer
notre position
avec l'Algérie".
Dès lors, monsieur le ministre,
la France va-t-elle dénoncer cet
accord franco-algérien?
A défaut de suivre
les recommandations
du RN, on peut espérer
que vous allez prendre
en compte
celles qui émergent
de vos rangs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Laurence Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Permettez-moi
de remettre cet accord
dans un peu de contexte.
D'abord, la relation
entre la France
et l'Algérie
ne s'arrête pas à l'aspect
migratoire.
C'est un élément
important,
mais cela
ne résume pas du tout la richesse
des relations entre nos deux pays.
Ensuite,
nous sommes dans un travail
avec nos partenaires
algériens
pour approfondir
ces relations
dans l'esprit de l'accord d'Alger.
Vous le savez,
il a été signé
par les deux présidents,
français
et algérien, en 2022.
Nous allons aller de lavant
avec cet approfondissement,
et nous allons
être vigilants
dans le domaine
consulaire
et dans la délivrance
de laissez-passer,
pour les immigrants
en situation irrégulière
et pour les OQTF.
Vous citez l'accord de 1968.
La dénonciation
sèche de cet accord
n'est pas
pertinente,
tant pour des raisons
juridiques
que pour des raisons politiques.
Elle ne réglerait pas du tout
les difficultés,
comme vous le prétendez.
Au contraire, elle aurait beaucoup
d'inconvénients majeurs.
Nous serions
collectivement perdants.
Cet accord n'est pas figé,
il a évolué
à plusieurs reprises
par le passé
et nous allons travailler
dans cet esprit
pour améliorer les choses
dans le cadre existant.
C'est la voix
de la responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole
est à monsieur
Fabrice Le Vigoureux
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Fabrice Le Vigoureux:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Gabriel Attal.
Monsieur le ministre,
vous êtes en charge d'une
des plus belles missions
de notre République,
celle de l'école,
celle de la réussite
de nos enfants,
de leur épanouissement
et de leur savoir.
Parmi ces savoirs,
il y a les plus fondamentaux
dont dépendent tous
les autres, le français
et les mathématiques,
et notamment
la lecture, si essentielle
à l'esprit critique,
à la créativité
et aux aptitudes émotionnelles
et sociales
comme l'empathie,
le sens du dialogue,
de la nuance
et de la tempérance.
Même s'ils ont tendance
à se stabiliser,
voire à progresser
à l'entrée en sixième,
nos résultats
ne sont pas bons
et ils sont inégalitaires.
Nous le constatons
à longueur d'auditions
dans le cadre de notre mission
d'information
sur l'apprentissage de la lecture.
Comme nous le confirment
de nombreuses études,
dont Pisa,
plus d'un jeune
sur cinq a de très grandes
difficultés
en lecture.
Les vents contraires
sont nombreux:
des réseaux sociaux
aux algorithmes fous
qui abrutissent
dès le plus jeune âge
et dévorent
2700 heures d'élèves
de quatrième.
Les formations
initiales préparent mal
nos enseignants.
Après d'intenses
consultations
avec les principaux
acteurs de l'éducation
et une enquête à laquelle
230.000 enseignants
ont contribué,
vous êtes déterminé
à créer un véritable
choc des savoirs.
Pouvez-vous nous en relater
les grands chapitres
et ce que vous envisagez
spécifiquement
pour faire du livre
un compagnon
de route de nos enfants,
et de la lecture
une porte ouverte
vers la culture
et l'émancipation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
la question
de tout à l'heure
m'a permis de parler
des mathématiques.
Vous me permettez d'aborder
la question fondamentale
de la lecture.
On parle souvent
des savoirs fondamentaux.
En réalité,
s'il
en est un qui est
plus fondamental
que tous les autres,
c'est la lecture.
On ne peut pas répondre
à un problème mathématique
si on ne peut pas lire l'énoncé.
Nous constatons trop souvent
les difficultés
de nos élèves en lecture
et en écriture.
Grâce à l'action résolue
de cette majorité,
nous avons amélioré les choses
en école primaire.
La France
est le seul pays
dont les élèves
progressent en CM1
sur cette question.
Cela montre
que les choix
que nous avons faits
depuis 2017
sont les bons,
il nous faut juste
les amplifier.
J'ai pu lire
vos travaux et regarder
à distance
les auditions
que vous avez réalisées
dans le cadre
de votre mission.
Je crois profondément
qu'on se rejoint
sur la nécessité
absolue
d'avoir des manuels
scolaires labellisés
avec des méthodes
approuvées
par la science
et la pratique
comme efficaces
à l'apprentissage
de la lecture et de l'écriture.
C'est ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion d'annoncer.
Il faudra aller
plus loin sur l'entrée
et l'éveil à la lecture,
dès les premières années
de la vie.
Avec la place
des écrans
chez les plus jeunes,
nous sommes devant une catastrophe
sanitaire et éducative.
Un enfant de moins de six ans
passe aujourd'hui quasiment autant
d'heure devant un écran
qu'en classe
dans l'année.
Il faut être capable
de renforcer l'éveil
à la lecture
à travers les livres
qui sont fournis aux élèves.
Nous travaillons en lien
avec les bibliothèques.
Ca se poursuit
avec les mesures annoncées
pour le collège et le lycée.
Nous allons faire
des groupes de niveau
dans ces disciplines
pour faire progresser
tous nos élèves.
Merci
de nous accompagner
dans cette direction.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame
Marianne Maximi.
- Marianne Maximi:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à la secrétaire d'Etat chargée
de l'Enfance.
Qui a dit: "La protection
de l'enfant sera
au coeur des cinq prochaines
années?"
C'est Emmanuel Macron.
Que s'est-il passé?
Rien.
La situation se dégrade
de jour en jour.
Tous les professionnels
de l'enfance
sont en alerte.
La protection de l'enfance s'est
littéralement effondrée.
Les mesures
de placement
ne sont plus mises en oeuvre.
Des enfants en danger
restent au domicile
des parents
alors que les juges ordonnent
leur placement.
Les professionnels
craquent: sureffectifs
dans les structures,
infanticides...
Un enfant meurt
tous les cinq jours
dans notre pays.
Ces dernières semaines,
nous avons franchi
un nouveau cap:
quatre départements
de droite annoncent
fièrement
ne plus respecter la loi:
ils suspendent
la protection
des enfants étrangers,
pas pour des raisons
budgétaires puisqu'ils
sont en bonne
situation budgétaire,
mais pour des raisons racistes.
Vous nous demandez
d'attendre,
mais quoi?
Nous attendons toujours
le décret d'application
de la loi qui a été votée.
Une nouvelle réforme
a fait les poches
des enfants placés
en diminuant
leur pécule.
Que faites-vous,
à part des campagnes
de communication?
Nous n'avons
plus de mots pour porter
à vos oreilles
la catastrophe
que nous vivons.
Le décalage
entre vos paroles,
les lois et la réalité
est insupportable.
Nous exigeons
un plan d'urgence
avec des moyens
pour augmenter les salaires,
pour recruter,
pour ouvrir des places.
Nous exigeons
le respect de la loi
et la protection
de tous les enfants,
quel que soit
leur département
et leur nationalité.
Agissez!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Charlotte Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Vous l'avez
dit,
nous ne vous avons pas
attendu
pour mesurer
l'étendue de la crise
qui ne date pas de 2017
sur la protection
de l'enfance.
Le président
de la République a décidé
d'en faire la priorité
du quinquennat,
qui s'est traduite
par la mise en place
d'un comité interministériel
dans lequel
nous avons pris
des engagements,
que nous mesurons au quotidien.
26 milliards d'euros
auront été mis
par ce gouvernement
et par cette majorité
au profit des enfants
les plus vulnérables.
C'est de l'argent
mis au profit
de la santé des enfants,
au profit
des enfants en situation
de handicap,
sur les plans de lutte
contre la violence,
et au titre de la prévention
et de l'action.
Vous nous reprochez des coups
de communication,
je vous reproche
votre vindicte,
qui contribue à porter
atteinte à l'image
de la protection de l'enfance.
Tous les jours,
au quotidien,
je suis sur le terrain
pour mettre
en valeur les bonnes
pratiques
de la protection de l'enfance,
les belles histoires
de la protection
de l'enfance,
et pour apporter le soutien
de l'administration
et du gouvernement
avec de l'argent sonnant
et trébuchant, et avec des actions
extrêmement concrètes.
De nombreux décrets
d'application
ont été pris.
Nous sommes dans un dialogue
constructif
avec les départements.
Pour la première fois,
la Première ministre
de ce gouvernement
a annoncé un temps fort
en termes de protection
de l'enfance
à l'occasion
de l'assemblée générale
des départements.
Dans quelques jours,
l'ensemble
des départements
représentatifs
et le gouvernement
vont se réunir
pour fixer des priorités
et des engagements réciproques.
Nous agissons
pour tous les enfants.
Je suis sur le terrain
pour mesurer ça.
Nous étions cinq ministres
tout à l'heure
à recevoir le livre blanc
du travail social
pour nous engager.
Pardonnez-moi si,
parfois,
nous ne montrons pas
suffisamment
notre action.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
La parole est à madame
Josiane Corneloup
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Josiane Corneloup:
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
des Solidarités
et des Familles.
Le Secours populaire français,
la Croix-Rouge,
les Restos
du Coeur subissent
depuis un an la crise
inflationniste
que nous connaissons.
De nombreux publics
nouveaux les sollicitent
pour obtenir une aide alimentaire.
Près de 9 millions de personnes
en France éprouvent aujourd'hui
des difficultés à s'alimenter
convenablement.
De plus,
une augmentation alarmante
des charges
logistiques menace
leur existence même.
La Première ministre,
en novembre 2022,
a annoncé l'attribution
de plusieurs millions d'euros
pour une aide alimentaire durable.
Ce fonds s'est
concrétisé par la mise
en oeuvre du plan
Mieux manger
pour tous.
Tous ont pris acte
de façon positive
de ce nouveau fonds
qui allait permettre
de renforcer
leurs nombreuses actions
sur le terrain.
Or, au 19 octobre
2023, ils n'ont pu
se saisir
de toutes les opportunités
pour mieux aider
les plus précaires
sur le plan alimentaire
car aucun fond n'est arrivé
alors que l'inflation
a bien continué
de progresser.
Le commissaire
européen, membre
de la Commission
européenne sur l'emploi
et les droits
sociaux, interrogé
par ces mêmes associations,
a indiqué qu'une partie importante
de la dotation
française au titre
du fonds européen d'aide
aux plus démunis,
2014-2020,
n'avait pas encore fait
l'objet d'appel de fonds
de la France auprès
de la Commission européenne.
Or, la fin de la période
d'éligibilité
est fixée au 31 décembre 2023.
Il est donc
plus qu'urgent de capter
ce potentiel financier restant.
Aujourd'hui, 5 décembre,
en cette Journée mondiale
du bénévolat,
je veux saluer
toutes les personnes
qui ne comptent
ni leur temps
ni leur peine pour aider
les autres.
Il serait
incompréhensible
pour eux que cet
argent soit perdu.
Je porte ici la voix
des associations
qui aident
les plus démunis
tout au long de l'année
et qui attendent
des réponses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Il n'y aura
évidemment pas un seul euro
qui va manquer.
C'est l'engagement
que nous avons pris
sur la question
de l'aide alimentaire
et c'est l'engagement
qui sera tenu.
Nous avons reçu hier,
avec Bruno Le Maire,
le président des Restos du Coeur.
Cet engagement sera tenu.
Sur le fond
alimentaire,
ce n'est pas l'Union
Européenne
qui attribue les crédits,
il faut d'abord dépenser
pour être remboursé.
Ce n'est pas
de l'argent
qui n'a pas été
cherché,
nous sommes allés
chercher
tous les crédits
que nous pouvions avoir.
Evidemment
que nous allons continuer
à le faire.
Il y a le programme
Mieux manger
pour tous.
Les associations
se félicitent
de la nouvelle
manière avec laquelle
nous avons travaillé.
Traditionnellement,
elles faisaient appel
à de la ramasse
et a de la lutte
contre les invendus.
Les personnes
les plus vulnérables doivent
aussi avoir accès
à de l'alimentation
de qualité,
avec des produits frais
et locaux.
Nous avons l'agriculture
la plus saine
et la plus durable au monde.
Il y a 1200 candidats
qui ont demandé
à bénéficier de ce plan.
479 ont été retenus et tous
les crédits seront
engagés avant de la fin
de l'année.
Sur les 60 millions d'euros
du plan Mieux manger
pour tous, 20
millions d'euros
sont désormais
des crédits locaux
pour aider les plus petites
associations partout
dans les territoires
et dans les départements.
L'an prochain, c'est 70
millions d'euros
qui existeront pour ce plan.
Nous continuons notre engagement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est suspendue.